Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today I am going to show you a paper and I
am almost out of words.
It is so good.
You know what, let’s jump right in.
This new AI is very much like DALL-E 2, which
is a text to image AI.
Our text goes in, an image comes out.
And this new paper is not text to image, but
music.
Yes, a piece of text goes in, and some hopefully
amazing music comes out.
Now, let’s see what it can do.
Let’s ask for an epic soundtrack with orchestral
instruments.
And, do we let the AI get away with such a
simple prompt?
Of course not!
The piece should build tension, and create
a sense of urgency, and you know what?
Add an a capella chorus on top of it.
There is no way that an AI could generate
something like that, right?
Well, hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars,
and listen.
That was incredible.
We will see in a moment how incredible exactly.
Now let’s give this AI an even harder time.
Oh yes, we wish for a bass and drums led reggae
song, with electric guitar, very difficult.
But it gets even worse.
Vocals.
Expressive vocals with a laid-back style.
There is absolutely no way that this is happening.
But just in case, let’s listen.
I can’t believe it.
Electric guitars, checkmark, I loved the intonation
and the personality, and the vocals were also
something else.
Wow.
Now, let’s ask for something completely
different.
We are real scholars, so we are going to ask
for real, 8-bit arcade music.
Holy mother of papers, now that’s a song
that has momentum, intensity, a great guitar
riff.
I am truly stunned.
The prompt also asked for unexpected sounds.
I have to admit I am not sure about that part,
but the rest was incredible.
But not as incredible as these four other
things that is can also do.
One, we already know that we can ask for some
piano playing, but it gets better.
We can ask it to be a beginner piano player,
or a real pro.
Let’s see.
Now that’s super cool, loving it.
Two, these were only 30-second sequences.
Most songs are significantly longer than that,
and there is a problem with that.
What is the problem?
The problem is that these AI-based techniques
have trouble with long-term coherence.
That means that a couple minutes into the
song, they don’t quite remember what they
played.
And that is indeed a problem, because writing
music is about building up a melody, and we
have to remember the melody and embellish
it over time.
So, what can this one offer in this area?
What’s this?
You are kidding right?
A 5-minute long song?
Well, let’s give it a shot, we will listen
to small snippets of this jazz song from different
parts.
Now this was truly something.
For about 3 minutes, it felt like one coherent
song, and after that, it did not morph into
another one, but I feel that it lost some
coherence.
However, it was not too far.
Let’s say that this was 1.5 songs.
That is an insane result because many previous
techniques could barely stay coherent for
even a few seconds.
A few minutes is science fiction region.
And all this, just one more paper down the
line.
My goodness.
Three, it can even image what paintings would
sound like.
I have to admit that I did not find these
samples too convincing, however, the one for
Starry Night was pretty good.
This is tranquil, soothing song, with a hint
of mysteriousness.
It’s not perfect, but I like it a great
deal.
And I think the capability is there for all
of these paintings, it is truly up to us humans
writing a good prompt to make them come alive.
But wait, four what happens if we write a
prompt and we don’t quite like the results?
Well, it can generate several variants.
In fact, as many as you wish.
So, I promised that I would tell you how good
it exactly it.
So how do we know that?
Well, through a user study.
Get some humans in the room, show them some
real music, some AI music from this technique
and from previous works, and see which one
they like best.
And the results are truly something else.
MusicCaps is real music, so that should win
most of the time.
That is not surprising.
However, what is really surprising is that
it does not win all the time, and it gets
even better.
Look at that!
The new technique, MusicLM is rapidly closing
in.
And remember, DALL-E 1 was an okay text to
image AI, and just one more paper down the
line, this is what DALL-E 2 was capable of.
And with all this, I am convinced that we
are at a DALL-E 2 moment for music generation.
It only gets better from here on out.
And just imagine what we will be able to do
two more papers down the line.
What a time to be alive!
So, what do you think?
What prompts would you like to try in the
future?
And what paintings would you like to come
to life?
Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!